Today, we're making a chickpea carbonara
with shiitake bacon and crispy leeks.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
It's delicious.
So the first thing we're gonna do actually, Drew,
I think your pot of water should be boiling.
We're just gonna drop in our pasta.
So we're actually using a chickpea pasta
which makes it gluten free.
You can use any other gluten free noodle
or you can use a regular wheat noodle.
So that's going, that's boiling, doing its thing.
So in my pan over here I have some leeks
which is gonna be the base of our sauce.
So I've been sauteing these leeks
until they get really soft and caramelly.
You can start with, Drew can start on the garnish actually.
So you have more leeks.
You're gonna make the shiitake bacon.
So in this tray, basically,
we're making the topping, the crispy topping.
So it's gonna be shiitake bacon.
And what that is is shiitake mushrooms
that we've sliced fine,
and we've seasoned with salt and pepper,
some olive oil and paprika, actually.
And what happens is when you put these in the oven,
you're gonna go 375 for about 25 minutes.
And the mushrooms are gonna get really, really nice
and crispy as will the leaks.
So we're gonna walk these over.
They have like a crispy and a chewy, just like bacon does.
And if you're a vegetarian
or you're looking to get more vegetables in your week
rather than meats
and find that balance as a flexitarian,
mushrooms like are most vegetarians' meat.
That's why there's like a portobello burger
and all of that stuff too.
So the garnish, this is for the topping of the pasta,
and we're gonna have that cool.
Now, Drew, sorry about that.
Earlier I jumped ahead a little bit
and I was talking about the sauce that we made.
So basically it's all these leeks that get caramelized down.
And to this I'm gonna add a little bit of miso
and I do a little aquafaba.
And you actually have the puree over there already ready.
So what you do with this sauce is you cook it down,
you simmer it until all those flavors meld,
and then you blend it so it becomes like-
Am I putting this in my pan?
Mm-hmm.
It becomes this very beautiful creamy sauce.
Aquafaba is such an amazing ingredient.
It's the water that the chickpeas come in,
and it's really enriching to a dish.
And then, Drew, what I like to do over here
is actually just take a ladle full of pasta water
into that dish.
So this is a little bit of yuzu juice.
Yuzu is a east Asian citrus.
And if you don't have yuzu, you could also use lime.
It works really beautifully.
And that just like brightens everything up.
And so my sauce is almost done.
And what I'm gonna do
is we have some of the cooked noodles over here
and we're gonna pop those in.
And you want it to feel
like with most like cream pastas, Drew,
you want it to feel slightly overdressed.
You want it on the wetter side
because as it sits and cooks,
that is basically just gonna absorb
all that beautiful, beautiful sauce.
All right, I am ready to plate mine up.
How are you doing over there, Drew?
I'm doing really well.
(loud banging)
(audience laughing)
Rebel homemaker.
It is not called I am perfect and trying to pretend to be,
it's called get it into the dish
so I can get it into my mouth.
(audience applauding)
So I like to scoop a little bit more of that sauce
'cause I love it.
I love that sauce.
And then we're gonna do some chives.
And then the beautiful crispy leaks and bacon
for that crunch.
I'm just going in with my hands.
Oh, I like that.
(audience applauding)
All right, little bird's nest there.
I love it.
Now, if you wanna get fancy,
the special occasion ingredient that can go on top
is a trout roe.
Or a salmon roe also would work.
So that little like pop of goodness, saltiness.
So, so delicious.
And that beautiful color.
I'm salivating right now.
Shall we?
(audience applauding)
Serve hot?
Serve hot.
Cheers.
I really taste the yuzu.
It's so bright.
It's strange that something so comforty and creamy
with also an earthy mushroom base
can be so citrusy and bright.
It still feels really fresh, right?
Very fresh.
And even up until the roe,
the whole dish is completely vegan,
and you can make it completely gluten free.
So just something to keep in mind.
(audience applauding)
This is one I truly love
and is really you and me in a bowl.
Absolutely.
Never said that before.
No.
(audience applauding)
This is so special.
Pilar, you and me in a bowl.
There you go.
Cheers.
I love you.
Thank you so much.
Check out our full recipe on the TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
from our cookbook "Rebel Homemaker."
(upbeat music)